[Musique]
bonjour édition spéciale du 7-8
politique en ce mois de novembre avec un
débat entre les candidats qui se
présentent à l'élection municipale de
coignières premier tour de scrutin le 25
novembre suite à la démission de
l'ancien maire jean pierre sauvestre je
reçois trois têtes de listes ali
bousselham bonjour monsieur coignières à
venir david pelletier
donc je dois agir ensemble pour coignard
et puis didier fischer ont soigneusement
pour un nouvel élan pour coignières
avant de se rendre dans votre commune
pour écouter et quelques-uns des
électeurs sur leur sentiment sur la
situation actuelle situation assez
chaotique avec une ancienne majorité qui
s'est divisée nous allons faire un
premier tour de table rapidement je vais
suivre l'ordre des candidatures en
préfecture
ali bousselham vous êtes né en 1958
enseignants vous étiez deuxième adjoint
au sein de l'équipe sortante
pourquoi cette candidature cette fois ci
en tant que tête de liste à coignières
et bien vous l'avez un petit peu exprimé
vous même
il ya eu un grand d accord dont on
reparlera tout à l'heure concernant un
projet de fusion et qui avait mis en
avait d'autres en amont mais qui était
beaucoup plus on va dire aux coulisses
et il ya eu des mouvements de population
et
suite à ces mouvements de population
j'ai pensé qu'il était opportun
qu'aujourd'hui je donne une réalité à ce
moment là on nous présentant une liste
sans étiquette communiste sans étiquette
effectivement trouvé un tous les trois
vous êtes sans étiquette c'est pour ça
que je viens à préciser le nom de votre
liste à chaque fois david mennecier vous
êtes maire en 1979 cadre dans le secteur
privé adjoint aux finances
dans la majorité sortante pourquoi cette
candidature même question en tête de
liste et cette fois ci écoutez je pense
que coignières aujourd'hui a besoin de
de renouveau vraiment dans sa
modernisation et la disent que je
représente a vraiment de grands projets
d'avenir pour cette ville
on a pris beaucoup de retard sur un
certain nombre de francs et nous voulons
faire bouger les choses c'est pour ça
que nous avons proposé notre candidature
aux habitants didier fischer mais en
1957 professeurs du secondaire déjà
candidat par le passé notamment en 2014
vous y aviez vous aviez réunit 43 % des
suffrages vous siégez jusqu'à présent
dans l'opposition pourquoi cette
nouvelle candidature
c'est une candidature qui apparaît
naturel j'étais tête de liste en 2014 je
suis aujourd'hui tête de liste notre
liste nouvel élan pour coignières est
une liste je dirais de large union
et je suis assez fier effectivement de
mener cette liste avec des candidats qui
volent l'intérêt le bien de ma commune
pour nous notre connu notre meilleure
pour débuter ce débat on écoute les
coignard jan bucquoy n'y a rien que
pense-t-il de cette situation actuelle
micro-trottoir de patrick jacques de
dixmude la situation je vois c'est que
la dernière fois qu'il ya eu qu'à
générer la crise là
miss perry t c'était effectivement la
fusion qui voulaient y avoir avec mauroy
or moi je suis complètement opposé à
cette fusion je comprends pas que les
gens puissent encore sur ce lit se
revendiquer de non pas de cette fusion
mais ce sont les mêmes personnes qui se
présentent sur les listes sur les deux
principales listes là qui sont des
listes sur lesquelles des gens avaient
voté pour avait négocié pour la fusion
avec mort par bastia ce que cognac
conserve son entité c'est sur ce projet
de fusion va du peu que j'en sais je
suis pas énormément les activités mines
les actualités municipal mais il a il
m'a l'air d'avoir été pas amené de la
bonne manière donc
je pense qu'il ya un petit problème de
communication une anticipation les gens
ont découvert ça un petit peu
de manière un peu subite réaction un peu
épidermique à ce projet puis les gens
n'ont pas forcément compris non plus
nous ce qu'on souhaite c'est le
malheureux et conçoit konya lien est pas
vendu quelque part
voilà le tour c'est cette question de la
fusion avec marc parent qui est revenu
le plus souvent lorsque nous sommes
rendus dans les rues de coignières on va
en parler dans un instant je veux juste
préciser que le débat sera chronométrée
est d'ores et déjà chronométrés afin
d'assurer l'égalité de temps de parole
entre ces candidats à la municipalité de
coignières vous êtes tous à peu près à
une vingtaine de secondes
ali bousselham votre réaction peut-être
à ce qu'on vient d'entendre mais écoutez
c'est clair peut-être pour un des
intervenants il semblait que pas avoir
compris que dans ma liste il y avait
justement des noms fusent yunist ma
liste en fête est née essentiellement
fin aujourd'hui 1 mais elle est née
effectivement de 7,2 cette volonté de ne
pas voter du tout ce projet là votre
position est claire sur ce rapprochement
ne mord pas puisqu'on va clarifier les
airs pour les électeurs de coignières
n'y a absolument aucun projet de fusion
dans notre projet c'est ça a été la
genèse de notre mouvement au départ qui
s'appelait qui séparait la majorité
municipale parce qu'on est que nous
n'étions pas d'accord du tout pour ça
donc effectivement je comprends que les
poignées rien je réagisse comme nous et
certainement que mes concurrents ici
présent vous dit que vous en diront plus
sur la question va vous faire réagir les
uns et les autres je rappelle cette idée
de fusion avec mort pas une idée qui
avait été évoquée finalement abandonné
face à une opposition justement d'une
partie aussi de la population et c'est
ce qu'il ya aujourd'hui engendré la
démission ensuite notamment de
jean-pierre sevestre et cette nouvelle
élection à coignières pour vous
coignières est une commune qui peut
rester seul audio de ces 4500 habitants
elle peut se débrouiller seuls ou est ce
qu'elle doit fusionner elle peut rester
seuls sont sans aucun doute
moi je voudrais un petit peu rappelé la
genèse de ce projet qui
ea qui naquit n'a jamais été finalement
un projet de fusion mais simplement un
projet de l'étude
aujourd'hui on sait que et on là je me
permets tu t'es une conférence de presse
commune des deux mers un de maurepas et
douanières sur ce dossier sur la mise en
place d'études
oui tout à fait ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que on l'a vécu dans le passé
l'intercommunalité qu'on avait donc
qu'on a qu'on avait refusé pendant un
moment puisque coignard voulait voulait
rester seul elle nous a finalement été
imposée par l'état
il est le premier j'étais saint quentin
en yvelines pour ensuite il revenir en
2016 tout à fait et le la première
personne qui en a parlé
finalement conseiller municipal c'est
vous monsieur fisher je m'en rappelle
très bien c'est de conseil municipal du
du 26 mars
mendier en dix ans en disant qu'on était
dans une logique de fusion voilà ça ne
me plaisait pas que l'état pourrait
c'est vrai c'est fou c'est en effet à
faire fusionner les communes oui oui
tout à fait voulait évaluer et il a
fallu que je me rende son ce film max et
ailleurs mais je m'en suis quand même
rendu compte et je l'avais je vois venir
le je vous laisse répondre et je dis
juste que la personne qu'on avait parlé
c'est effectivement monsieur fisher pour
la ce que c'est évidemment il y avait il
ya eu une alerte face à la baisse des
dotations de l'état
l'état avait fait cette proposition
dédié vous laisser ça comme ça ben je le
juge comme ça et je le jeu le confirment
tous les frais qu'ils aient pas nous et
l'état proposait l'état l'état propose
est effectivement la possibilité de
communes nouvelles et donc nous avions
émis l hypothèse effectivement de lancer
ses études et ce qui était présenté au
conseil municipal du 2 mai c'était
uniquement un projet d'étude et par
rapport à ce qui a été dit parce que je
pense qu'il ya eu aussi beaucoup de
désinformation auprès des habitants c
est gelé la cette délibération elle
prévoyait bien le vote de tous les
habitants dans le cas où les études
auraient été favorables
si les études avaient pas été favorables
le projet serait arrêté droite bien
clair qui fait partie de l'ancienne
majorité en tous cas
la scission qui a eu lieu vous ne portez
pas aujourd'hui un projet de futur de
fusion vous avez évoqué à l'époque
l'idée d'une probable fusion d'une
possible fusion en fonction des études
c'est que vous leur dites moi en tant qu
adjoint aux finances
il m'intéressait parce que je trouve qu
un élu responsable et prend ses
décisions sur des études sur des faits
sur des analyses et donc prendre la
bonne décision c'est tout d'abord avoir
des études et aujourd'hui j'étais
favorable la société j'étais enfin le
râble aux études ce qui ne veut pas dire
que j'aurais été favorable à ce soir des
nouvelles études qui seront faites si
vous êtes élu maire non non ça c'est
clair
voilà je les j'ai pris cette décision
puisqu'elle était sur la place publique
et il y avait un certain nombre de
confusion puisque comme un monsieur de
l'adie effectivement il ya une très
mauvaise communication de notre part à
l'époque et il faut le reconnaître il
faut reconnaître ses erreurs donc
j'avais pris la décision parce qu'il
faut aussi assumer de mettre fin au
projet je les dis publiquement c'est
papa lui remettre c'est pas pour le
remettre aujourd'hui sur la place
publique et d'ailleurs dans ma liste la
majorité des gens n'étaient pas
favorables à ce projet lille et fisher
vous laisse réagir et puis nous dire que
vous êtes élu maire est ce que cette
question de fusion avec maurepas ou même
avec une autre commune se reposera à
noël se repose rapport non j'ai été un
des premiers opposants un mois je me
souviens bien effectivement de la
chronologie des faits le 9 avril c'est
la conférence de presse à la conférence
de presse vous y êtes avec un certain
nombre de collègues monsieur boucella
n'y est pas mais vous vous y êtes avec
un certain nombre de collègues et on
nous annonce clairement non pas des
études à ce moment là mais une fusion
est d'ailleurs toute la presse le
comprend comme cela et relate
l'information comme comme une fusion le
soir réunion des élus
seul mon groupe pose des questions et
surtout s'oppose en effet à cette fusion
est clairement nous avons demandé à
monsieur sauvé s'il avait l'intention de
consulter la population par un
référendum
il nous a dit non ce soir là donc il est
clair qu'au départ il n'y avait pas
l'intention de faire un référendum n'est
pas l'intention de consultés par
référendum la population on allait faire
des études peut-être on allait faire des
petits ateliers on allait donner un peu
la parole mais la sphère elle était dans
le sac est depuis longtemps à mon avis
c'est des choses qui sont assez ce que
vous estimez
je précise que je vais vous faire ce que
j'aime les choses après on va évoquer
d'autres sujets aussi puisque nous
devons unir pour des baies et nous avons
très rapidement c'est à dire le
lendemain diffusé un tract à la
population dénonçant la fusion et
ensuite à la fin de la semaine le
vendredi nous avons commencé à faire
circuler une pétition
nous avons obtenu 1547 signature sur
2400 électeurs à coignières ça veut dire
que majoritairement ce que nous venons
d'entendre ici est exact la majorité
majorité de la population est hostile à
lyon vous souvenez vous souvenez du
démon suis né du wihrel de celle de ce
rassemblement devant la mairie le 2 mai
il est clair que là nous avions
peut-être pas tous poignet mais nous
avions une représentation de notre
commune vaste en dehors de tout je
dirais clivage ou représentation
politique et ces gens qui étaient là ne
souhaitait pas en effet voir gouesnière
perdre son indépendance perdre son
identité et devenir un quartier de
maurepas
si je résume les positions qui sont
exposés ici aucun de nous trois s'il est
élu maire le 25 novembre lors du
deuxième tour au mois de décembre ne
reviendra sur cette question de fusion
avec mortage vous laisse réagi
rapidement
oui après rapidement j'ai juste reçu
j'ai d'une manière prévoir les tendances
actuelles
la première chose c'est que les études
quand j'ai demandé le cahier des charges
ce n'était pas des études pour envisager
l'hypothèse d'une fusion mais la mise en
oeuvre donc j'ai eu déjà un conflit
sévère avec l'ancien maire sur la
question parce que je dis peut-on amendé
cela que la rupture allait venir
et la deuxième chose pour le savoir
quand même ce sont les élus de
l'ancienne majorité par le refus de vote
et des études tout le reste qui ont
stoppé net
cette fusion a rien ne pouvait le faire
vous savez tous les jours devant
l'assemblée nationale et des gens qui
font des manifestations sans n'empêche
pas monsieur bousselham vous n'aviez pas
une majorité
le jour de l'annoncé de la fusion et
dans les quelques jours qui ont suivi la
majorité elle s'est constituée quand
justement justement la population l'as
rome se lâchent qu'ils n'avaient pas
tant de la population avec une énorme
attendez laissez moi finir s'il vous
plaît il faut quand même mais à six mois
l'assignation page et c'est là parce que
c'est la population qui a fait cette
fois que certains élus sont inchangés
vous étiez au delà d'une démo certains
élus je viens juste une chose
aujourd'hui je pense que ma faute à moi
peut-être se jettent sur les iphone et
vous prendrez a plutôt que cette saison
réalisation avancer sur la question tous
les horizons s'il vous plaît monsieur
fisher également s'il vous plaît on va
on va évoquer l avenir de cette semaine
de coignières aussi si on peut préparer
les temps parole d un réservoir de
chacun au nez si vous voulez vous
exprimer sur tous les sujets le mieux
c'est de garder du temps de parole du
voile a d'autre part évoqué un nom bien
d'autres sujets voilà ce qu'on va voir
les temps de parole des uns et des
autres sera évoqué la véritable débat et
aux vrais enjeux de cette élection qui
sont les paroles des uns et des autres
et ali bousselham a le plus de retard il
est à moins de deux minutes je vous fait
réagir sur la suite on parle de cette
question de maurepas on pourrait aussi
évoquer la question de la piscine on va
sans doute y venir intercommunale aussi
parce que les quoi n'y a rien qu'on y
revienne se pose la question est-ce que
coignard fera ou non partie où doit ou
non faire partie de cette création de
nouvelles piscines se remarque pas avec
la ville d'elancourt
juste auparavant peut-on évoquer saint
quentin en yvelines est ce
qu'aujourd'hui coignières est
représentée à sa juste valeur dans
l'agglomération je pense que non je suis
même sûr que l'on puisse que nous avons
encore à 7 euros alors que lens dont je
vous parle ainsi qu'une seule personne
représentante de notre commune c'est
madame catelin à la première adjointe le
la démission de monsieur ce geste n'a
pas été suivi le bar l'élection d'un
autre conseiller de la majorité et
accessoirement qu'il puisse représenter
et défendre des intérêts de notre
commune au sein des 52 ans et lui la
ville de coignières qui siègent au sein
de la new trabi endroit absolument nous
avons droit à deux de représentants il
n'en a pas aujourd'hui il y en a pas et
je le regrette évidemment mais quand
même on est citoyen de parent isolé que
c'est ça que je veux dire l'un d'eux va
aujourd'hui de coignières au sein de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines
puisqu'au début coignard ne voulait plus
en faire partie vous l'avez rappelé tout
à l'heure en introduction coignard a été
forcé de par la loi de devenir au sein
d'une agglomération est revenu à la
soirée sur la grille
ne faisait déjà pas partie depuis 1995
ne faisait plus partie des bus à la
création de la ville nouvelle coignard
ne sais pas s'il vrai voilà c'était pas
la même ville new wave c'est le ska
c'était en tout cas objets relatifs et
on en est sortie c'était c'était bien
que l'état permette la ville de
coignières de vivre en toute liberté
nous avons prospérer notre ville a
prospéré d'une manière tout à fait
harmonieuse et raisonnable et il n'était
pas question de retourner dans un
ensemble gigantesque qui allait nous
absorber d'une certaine façon est
maintenant que vous y êtes
ben maintenant qu'on y est on est sûr
c'est que je crois que ça se passe pas
aussi bien que je l'aurais aimé je ne le
cache pas maintenant après tout c'est
une question de négociation discussions
avec nos autres collègues de
l'agglomération pour que la place de
coignières puis c'est une véritable
place vous prétendons pas nous sommes la
plus petite commune nous n'allons pas
prétendre peser d'un poids énorme mais
néanmoins on est là il n'existe si je
suis élu c'est sûr ils vont s'apercevoir
que nous existons des sacs entiers comme
question quelle place pour contenir au
sein de saint quentin en yvelines parce
que là aussi ça fait partie des
inquiétudes qu'on peut entendre dans les
rues de coignières l'a déjà ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est qu'on est la plus
petite commune
donc c'est pour ça aussi qu'on est la
moins représentée que normalement on
devrait même avoir qu'un siège on a
finalement 2 je pense je pense
aujourd'hui que malgré le fait qu'on
soit la plus petite commune on peut être
plus acteur et plus partenaire de saint
quentin en yvelines
il ya beaucoup de projets qui peuvent
être mené en commun moi je veux dans
l'hypothèse où ma liste sera élu j'ai
déjà entamé un certain nombre de
négociations parce que ça me paraît
important de savoir où on peut aller
jusqu'où on peut aller
je crois je crois aujourd'hui saint
quentin en yvelines est un partenaire je
fais pas partie des gens qui ont été
contre l'intercommunalité puisque toute
façon elle est imposée il faut faire
avec mais il faut en tirer les avantages
et les avantages aujourd'hui on en a eu
puisque saint quentin en yvelines a pris
en charge les deux millions d'euros pour
la mise en application du pprt et je
pense que demain on peut aller plus loin
parce que sur le numérique à l'école qui
est une chose aussi très importante avec
aussi le département sur l'emploi qui
est catastrophique à coignières avec 12
% de chômage et c'est une compétence de
saint quentin en yvelines sur la voirie
sur laquelle on a énormément de retard
et
saint quentin en yvelines une fois de
plus peut nous apporter des choses je
crois qu'il faut vraiment travailler
dans un partenariat gagnant gagnant avec
saint quentin en yvelines et moi c'est
ce que j'ai envie de faire d'idée
fischer place de coignières sur sur la
place de poignard dans 50 ans niveler
une bombe rien de certain nombre de
choses qui ont été dites 1 c'est
effectivement c'est la plus petite
commune mais c'est pas la plus petite
part le poids économique il faut quand
même pas oublier cela c'est à dire que
nous pesons économiquement et nous avons
été très courtisé pour entrer dans saint
quentin en yvelines
moi je voudrais simplement rappeler que
il court encore deux recours en ce qui
concerne cette je dirais la présence de
coignières et maurepas aussi dans saint
quentin en yvelines
ota l'instruction est close il rend un
jugement dans les deux peut-être dans
les deux ou trois mois qui viennent en
ce qui concerne cela donc il n'est pas
exclu non plus que 50 parce que comme
coignières et et maurepas sorte de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines bon si
poignard et maurepas ne sortent pas de
saint quentin en yvelines
il est évident qu'il faut défendre notre
place et aujourd'hui elle n'a pas été
défendu je dirais sa juste mesure cette
place moi je voudrais rappeler quand
même un certain nombre de supports on a
laissé passer un certain nombre de
subventions pour nos investissements à
160 170 mille euros l'année dernière
notamment alors que ça aurait peut-être
été intéressante par le directeur
financier
pas seulement merci les gars dur
j'espère que les tunnels pas certain
nombre de saisines a qu'un certain
nombre de commentaires positifs de deux
de subventions ne seront pas perdus et
les élections et nous sommes investis
sements qui est oui mais bien sûr oui ça
fait trois ans qu'on démarre pas
l'investissement donc ça c'est aussi un
problème à coignières on a un retard
d'au moins 3 années en termes
d'investissement donc on a effectivement
aujourd'hui au budget quelque chose
comme 5 millions d'euros à peu près 1
dans le budget pour l'investissement
donc voilà c'est quand même un problème
cela alors sinon moi je constate depuis
deux ans que le retour quand même
coignières participe beaucoup à cette
intercommunalité puisque sur les 8 et
quelques millions 9 millions à peu près
de nos zones d'activités
disons on nous en nous en redonne à peu
près 5 millions 5 millions cent cette
année quatre millions 8 peut-être
l'année prochaine
ça veut dire qu'ils soient même 4
millions 8,9 millions ça c'est là c'est
la totalité de ce que perçoit saint
quentin sur les zones d'activités c'est
effectivement contrôlable ça et on a un
retour en attributions en attributions
de compensation de 5 millions que sans
fin 7 millions grâce à des projets à une
5 millions où j'organise ça tourne
autour de 5 millions us
donc c'est pas le goût chief donc nous
verrons où on vérifiera vous verrez on
est on est dans son nez dans ses lancers
roularta bien justement on verra donc
j'estime qu'avec la participation de
coignières aujourd'hui le retour que
nous avons est très faible
cette intercommunalité pour l'instant
reste quand même très confiscatoire
alors moi je nomme je n'aspire
évidemment qu'à une chose c'est que les
choses évoluent dans les années qui
viennent et que poignet est
véritablement sa place dans cette
intercommunalité si nous restons dans
cette intercommunalité survenait en tant
qu elles ont vedette vous prenez un peu
d'avancé sur le temps de parole qu'on va
revoir dans un instant j'aimerais
évoquer aussi au cours de ce débat les
différents points de programme on vous
entendu vous prononcer sur cette idée de
fusion pas sur la place de coignières au
sein de l'intercommunalité
quels sont aujourd'hui les points de
programme sachant que le temps pour agir
sera à court puisqu'il ya un scrutin le
25 novembre mais qu'en 2020 il y aura
une nouvelle élection municipale donc ça
laisse peu de temps pour agir
il ya quelques points forts on en a déjà
parlé
avec donc la rénovation de bâtiments nos
équipements c'est urgent d'autant plus
que je sais qu'il ya déjà des dossiers
qui sont prêt prêt à mettre mis en
oeuvre parce que les services et les
autres équipes les avait déjà préparé il
ya des chose faisable assez rapidement
revenir aussi sur le pea lui parce que
le pmu n'a pas pris en compte un certain
nombre d' aspiration de certaines
populations il faut le remettre sur la
table sur sens par pas remettre en
question l'économie générale du ps lui
forcément mais au moins le revoir ça
restait un petit peu sibyllin y compris
pour les gens qui étaient comme moi un
peu ostracisé entre guillemets et donc
un peu moins fort mais bon pour pour la
question enfin créer un vrai climat de
dialogue moi j'ai la chance de parler
avec les gens avec aisance son complexe
c'est une chance de l'exploiter pour de
le transférer en fer en faire quelque
chose comme étant un objectif d'un vrai
dialogue avec les différentes
populations avec les différentes
les différentes associations etc et puis
bien évidemment revenir un climat de
travail apaiser les remettre la machine
en marche ça c'est le plus urgent dans
les quatorze mois après nous bâtirons
aussi c'est dans le programme jeux
peuvent déballer ici bien sûr nous
bâtirons aussi tout ce qui est
nécessaire pour après 2020
vous savez en 2020 nous tout le monde se
représentera devant les électeurs dont
ils feraient sûr il faut clag la commune
soit en état d'être prise aux prises par
rapport à ce moment là par une équipe
qui pourra continuer à oeuvrer dans
l'intérêt des quoi ni rien on va centrer
sur les besoins et les intérêts des
coignard rien david pelletier vous étiez
tous les deux au sein de la même
majorité il ya une fusion au sein de 7
c'est une fiction parlant fait pas
fusion on revient ce sujet ne porte pas
non et je ne m'en lasse pas sur cette
question en tout cas pas l'ail ou
séparation d'une partie de la liste d'un
côté et autres partis vers l'autre
aujourd'hui vous avez un programme
radicalement opposées mais je crois que
on est une petite commune donc il ya
forcément des choses dans les trois
grammes ce qui ce qui se sait les
souhaits des habitants donc forcément on
les retrouve un petit peu effectivement
la réhabilitation aujourd'hui de nos
bâtiments elle est essentielle alors
faut pas faut pas bâcler des
réhabilitations il faut le faire en
concertation avec les utilisateurs
on a des problèmes structurels et
notamment sur sur l'accès l'accès aux
normes handicap sur la plupart de nos
bâtiments publics donc c'est quand même
des gros projets et effectivement il ya
les finances pour les lancer même si 14
mois c'est court
ils peuvent déjà être lancé après il ya
l'éducation parce qu'aujourd'hui
hormis refaire les écoles il faut aussi
accompagner la révolution pédagogique
numérique et ça avec saint quentin en
yvelines et le département ça peut être
pris en charge et il faut en profiter
il ya aussi l'aspect sécuritaire parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est important il faut
avoir une commune qui est sûr et puis à
toute cette partie quand même activité
économique développement économique
puisqu'on est on est à un tournant de
l'activité économique sur coignières
avec un modèle des années 90 qui est
peut-être plus aujourd'hui le bon qui
entraîne peut-être aujourd'hui le
chômage qui assure la ville et ça il
faut oeuvrer vraiment dans ce sens
l'idée fischer oui bon il ya des choses
qui ont été dites un david pelletier a
effectivement justement fait remarquer
quand on est une petite commune qui
effectivement des choses que nous on a
tous constaté moi la seule chose que je
dirais là comme cela d'emblée vous aviez
vous avez exercé le pouvoir
tout ça pourquoi ça n'a pas été fait
pour qu'on a attendu dix ans pour le
gymnase pourquoi voilà donc alors il
c'est évident nous notre priorité notre
liste c'est revenir à la sérénité
ce qu'on a vécu ces derniers mois je
dirais c'est exceptionnel c'est
historiquement poignard n'a jamais vécu
ça donc je pense qu'il faut qu'on
revienne à un fonctionnement normal de
nos institutions
1 on se respecte c'est une situation
totalement inédite et je pense que
l'asse la priorité des priorités ce
retour ensuite défendre effectivement
coignières et ses habitants je pense que
ça c'est quelque chose de très important
bien sûr que nous aussi nous allons
faire un certain nombre de
réhabilitation à gymnase et ainsi de
suite
et puis on préparera à l'avenir sur un
on a l'idée d'une je dirais d'une maison
des associations des familles et des
jeunes par exemple un ça ça pourrait
être intéressant dans le cadre de notre
commune et puis d'une manière très forte
aussi et ses revenus dans tous les
débats dans toutes les réunions que je
fais lors de cette campagne
c'est le problème du chômage 1 12% c'est
quand même je dirais c'est
incompréhensible pour une commune qui a
autant d'entrées d'entreprises
allemandes est reprise effective c'est
osé on peut être fait du jour
c'est incompréhensible donc je pense
qu'il faut revenir sur le fonctionnement
de ce qui était la cellule emploi qui
est devenu le service de l'aide à
l'emploi là je pense que ça fonctionne
assez mal il faut travailler avec les
entreprises
il est nécessaire d'accompagner aussi un
certain nombre de jeunes et de moins
jeunes qui sont éloignés de l'emploi
donc tout ce travail va falloir qu'on le
fasse il faut qu'on engage les
professionnels évidemment pour faire ce
travail
rapidement il et puis deux longueurs
d'avancé aux graminées ont terminé sur
sur sur cela notre but aussi c'est
d'amener la population à participer à la
vie communale et on mettra en place des
conseils de quartier on sait qu'à
l'heure actuelle les comités
consultatifs n'ont pas bien fonctionné
il sera peut-être nécessaire de revenir
à des commissions plus traditionnel et
de faire des couilles de quartier pour
que la population s'en part évidemment
de son environnement de proximité et je
vous arrête la conclusion tout à l'heure
sera très rapide puisqu'il nous reste à
peu près deux minutes d'émission dont
vous aurez que quelques secondes par
rapport aux autres candidats je vais
vous laisser chacun livré un peu votre
conclusion à l'issue de ce débat on va
recommencer le cannabis trépied cinq ans
même si ça ne rend pas revoir le temps
de parole des uns et les autres de toute
façon juste peut-être dans cette
conclusion aussi nous dire votre point
de vue sur la piscine on en n'a pas du
tout parlé david pelletier je vous
écoute vous avez le goût est quasiment à
égalité avec lé bousselham soucier des
cinq minutes
je veux avant tout pour la piscine parce
que puisqu'on n'a pas abordé ce sujet on
sait que c'est que aujourd'hui nos
petits d'eau petits élèves quoi il n'ya
rien puissent apprendre à nager et qui
est cette garantie
donc aujourd'hui on est sorti du projet
initial
je veux pas me retrouver à être
dépendant d'un organisme privé qui veut
d'un opérateur privé qui va gérer la
piscine et je pense qu'il faut ré ouvrir
tout de suite le dialogue avec les
communes de maurepas d'elancourt est
aussi avec le département qui du coup
financera également à cet équipement
pour trouver une convention qui
permettent et la garantie des lignes
d'eau pour les écoles et aussi peut-être
des tarifs plus avantageux pour les
connais rien
j'enchaînais les îles en chêne lyon a
les gens chez centaine de secondes et
puis après nous nous ce qu'on veut on a
une équipe quand même qui est très
renouvelée puisque on est l'équipe qui a
le moins de siens conseillers municipaux
ce qu'on veut surtout c'est faire bouger
des choses c'est moderniser cette ville
et l'accompagner dans son développement
cas pas forcément été engagées au cours
des dernières décennies et on veut
vraiment marquer un tournant dans
l'histoire de coignières et la diriger
vers l'avenir par la révolution
numérique par le développement
économique et aussi par d'autres choses
que je n'aurais pas le temps de
développer aujourd'hui mais que les
habitants verront très très bientôt dans
notre combat se poursuivra bien
évidemment je vous disais qu'il ya
nécessairement du cousinage dans les
différents programmes parce que quand on
est à l'écouté quoi ni rien fatalement
nous intégrons lui ce que disent les
quoi ni rien donc il ya deux c'est tout
à fait normal je trouve même ça
intéressant c'est le redis encore 3
liste sans étiquette qui se présentaient
à 10 ans il était déjà quelque chose
c'est une singularité aussi c'est une
singularité
concernant la piscine pendant des
décennies la commune a été le client de
la piscine de maurepas le projet qui
était proposée était un projet assez
flou dans lequel on n'était pas
forcément dans de participation n'était
pas forcément équitable me semblait-il
donc il faut rediscuter c'est sûr de
demain peut-être peut-être qu'il faut
discuter mais on nous sommes prêts
aujourd'hui nous sommes clients d'une
autre d'une autre piscine municipale ou
là où vont quand nos écoliers parce
qu'on assurera continuera à assurer ce
genre de service auprès de la population
y compris les enfants vous savez je suis
très sensible à cela
mais demain sortira à mort par une
piscine intercommunale heurtrey léocour
maurepas nous nous présenterons comme
client est bien évidemment clients avec
une convention pour négocier sur quelque
chose
mais aujourd'hui en nettement nous il ya
qu un projet qui n'est pas encore
arrêtée nous semble-t-il enfin je n'ai
pas entendu dire que le projet est a été
arrêté je n'ai pas lu donc le jour il y
aura quelque chose à ce moment là nous
irons voir nos voisins discuterons avec
eux ils auront besoin de clients et nous
aurons besoin de natation pour nous pour
nos enfants et pour terminer va écouter
moi j'ai un autre message pour justement
comme nos cousineau entre guillemets
beaucoup dans nos programmes
moi je voudrais simplement donner le
message aux poignets rien que enfin la
parole leur est donné
ça y est il est temps ils vont pouvoir
s'exprimer je les invite à venir
nombreux à voter parce que quel que soit
leur choix
et là je veux même pas faire de la pub
pour moi mais quel que soit leur choix
ça lui donnera plus de valeur
s'attendant à une légitimité c'est vrai
que les élections sa demande intérieure
et extérieure puisque nous parlons de
nos partenaires nos voisins et nos amis
extérieurs plus important puisqu'on
nombreux plus je pense que c'est quelque
chose d'important
je les invite à bien regarder il ya du
cousinage dans les programmes
après il ya des gens d'expérience des
gens moins d'expérience et des gens
authentiques peut-être d'autres - il ya
une question de personnalité après la
différence se fera dans les airs d'été
fisher sur la piscine est ce qu'il faut
ouvrir le dialogue très rapidement être
fait rapidement sur la piscine où on
était opposé au projet effectivement
défendu par les trois communes puisque
nous n'était plus pour une
réhabilitation une extension de
l'existant à c'était beau quand même
beaucoup plus logique à mon sens et son
écoute et moins cher au final
bon là dessus la dsp concessive nous on
ne voulait pas bon maintenant on est
éjecté du projet si j'ai bien compris
donc il ya un an je fais ce mets mes
collègues c'est à dire qu'on passera une
convention pour essayer d'avoir ces
fameuses lignes d'eau et aussi peut-être
des prix raisonnables pour les poignées
rien dans le cadre de cet équipement bon
sinon et pour votre conclusion ce sera
aux 15 secondes pas plus parce que vous
allez nous avons fusion on est on est la
seule liste où nous n'avons pas de
conseillers municipaux en fait
qui ont été en responsabilité et qui ont
appartenu à la majorité donc d'une
certaine manière c'est une liste aussi
du renouvellement puisque cette liste a
été largement ouverte
il n'y a pas que des adhérents de
poignard pour tous sur cette liste un
petit tiers mais pas plus donc c'est une
liste aux couleurs de coignières et
j'espère en effet les poignées rien
viendront nombreux voter dimanche 25
novembre
attention de 8 heures à 18 heures
effectivement c'est bien de le
repréciser scrutin sera ouvert à 8
heures à 18 heures le 25 novembre bien
évidemment dans notre édition du journal
du lundi nous reviendrons sur les
différents résultats et éventuellement
sur les discussions de l'entre-deux
tours 6 second tour idiot à voir on voit
les temps de parole des uns et des
autres et je vous ai pas menti didier
fischer vous aviez beaucoup d' avance
voilà vous auriez vous avez été prévenus
en tout cas merci à tous les trois
d'être venu s'excuser par habitation
avant ce premier tour à coignières et on
se retrouve bientôt sur télé 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]